merci pour poser poser on
l' simuler la prise en charge d'une
situation de crise à plusieurs victimes
le temps d'une journée une centaine de
membres des délégation territoriale de
la Croix-Rouge accompagné d'étudiants de
formation médicale se sont exercés à la
prise en charge de nombreuses victimes
la manœuvre a commencé depuis maintenant
un peu plus d'une heure où on avait deux
dispositifs de secours qu'on a
l'habitude de mettre en place sur
différentes manifestations et au cours
de ces dispositifs de secours il y a eu
une situation notamment une simulation
d'une explosion et sur un autre
événement un mouvement de foule qui est
amené à avoir une situation à de
nombreuses victimes donc là où on a dû
déployer de de des moyens
supplémentaires pour venir en aide aux
équipes déjà sur place l'objectif de cet
exercice au centre hospitalier
intercommunal Melan les Mureau
appréhender des situations d'urgence et
créer une cohésion entre les secouristes
des différentes délégations
départementales présentes à la formation
1 2 3 souousmis à deux situations de
crise au même moment les secouristes
sont formés aux soins simultanés d'un
grand nombre de victimes dans les
meilleures conditions possible mett sur
la chaise d'accord pour pouvoir un ça
vous emmener voir un médecin d'accord
l'objectif c'est de réussir à faire en
sorte que le commandement soit capable
de prioriser en fonction des moyens
qu'il a à ses disposition au moment où
il prend des décisions en même temps de
garantir que nos secouristes sont
capables d'effectuer les gestes
techniques sur le terrain au moment où
on a besoin d'eux à l'approche des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 ces exercices
n'ont pas été choisis au hasard le but
est aussi de préparer au mieux la
sécurité de l'événement qui accueillera
plus de 16 millions de spectateurs on
peut se permettre de déplacer madame un
petit peu parce que pour glisser le oui
il va falloir de toute